despite the fact that
san francisco hair salons have been
closed locked up
for the most part until since the month
of march
that is nancy pelosi in the smock right
there
uh she's being followed by a man in san
francisco at 3 10 in the afternoon
at a place called e-salon even though
nobody could legally get a haircut
or any sort of treatment at indoor
personal care facilities
there is the speaker of the house
seemingly
breaking the rules and not wearing a
mask let's bring in dave rubin
host of the dave reuben show and author
of don't burn this book thinking
for yourself in an age of unreason he
joins us from california he's not
wearing a mask either
dave what do you think about the
hypocrisy here
that little video should be the video of
2020 because
that sums up with no audio it sums up
exactly what the democrats have decided
to do
which is do as i say not as i do
she's now claiming she didn't know what
the policy was you'd think that the
speaker of the house might know what the
policy is
but this stuff is not a joke because it
is destroying people's livelihoods as
you've done in a couple segments this
morning you know i'm here in california
and i'm i'm fighting to
to try to keep a sane california because
we've had a say in california in the
past let's not forget that ronald reagan
was once
the governor of california and i i have
two friends
actually who are hair stylists here in
los angeles both of them
have closed their salons i get now in
what i assume is an illegal haircut
in an open-air garage from one of them
who's out of the business all together
and she's just doing me a favor and i
have another one
who's got some makeshift thing out of
her house and as one person at a time
and knows that she can't
continue to make a living this way so
when you see
nancy pelosi do this it's very
reminiscent of just what two months ago
when she's standing in front of her twin
uh sub z zero the subzero fridges with
her with her tons of ice cream and she's
really at
the marie antoinette let them eat cake
phases
don't you think dave which is she's
gonna live however she wants
and and her constituents will live
another way yeah don't you think dave
it's time for all these hair salon
owners just to start opening up
that's their green light i mean the
speaker of the house just mocked the
suffering they're going through
by saying i'm going to do whatever i
want and now all these people got to go
out of business
they should just open up in mass how
could they stop all of them
after all it has worked in other states
even in this state
which uh which lives to hamstring people
here's what
don't you think that that might be an
option now
i think it's an option not only when it
comes to hair salons but when it comes
to restaurants and everything else and
that's not to minimize
the reality of covid but what that is is
to
realize the it's to minimize the reality
of the policies
the arbitrary policies that they're
putting in place
i mean if this is nancy pelosi is
pretending that she either didn't know
what the policy was
uh that she helped put into place or
that she didn't even know that the salon
was closed
just for her i mean she didn't think it
was odd that nobody else was there
we're realizing that we have a political
class who wants to operate one way while
the rest of us are going to have to
scrounge for our survival and that is
not a good recipe
for for a functioning society dave on
that note of her claiming not to know we
have a statement from drew hamill
her spokesman and this is what it says
the speaker always wears a mask
no she doesn't by the way and complies
with local covert requirements this
business offered for the speaker to come
in on monday and told her they were
allowed by the city
to have one customer at a time in the
business the speaker complied
with the rules as presented to her by
the establishment so clearly this is
untrue
you know she didn't have a mask on she
wasn't following the rules this is very
very clear now
that she thinks there's a separate set
of rules for her and it's interesting
too because she's been on tv
for months now talking about how she
takes the virus seriously
president trump does not and here she is
no mask in an establishment that has
is supposed to be closed it's utterly
ridiculous but dave we want to move on
to another topic because this this is
fascinating to me
joe biden and kamala harris have
released this video
i find the video very odd i want you to
weigh in on it they're talking about the
decency of americans what's important to
note is this was taped
august 21st and has just now been
released take a listen
i really believe that the vast majority
of the american people
are truly decent yes i think they're
angry right now i think they're fed up
i think they're looking for some
authenticity and
some honesty we're better than this
we are i'm really excited you're willing
to do this i am very excited about it
we're going to get this done joe
dave does this strike you as odd
yeah well authenticity if you think
you're gonna get authenticity from these
two
uh you've got another thing coming i
mean this really is a
a match made in hell and i i think most
people have to understand
if you're supporting biden or if you're
voting for the democratic nominee
you really are voting for kamala harris
and you only have to go back a couple
months
when kamala was still in the race
against biden and there's a truly
telling moment that everybody needs to
see
over and over again when joe biden was
asked about an executive action on
guns and he says it has to be
constitutional meaning you can only do
an executive action
if it's constitutional the the executive
branch can't just decide to do something
against the legislative branch that's
the way the system works
and kamala harris laughs in his face
and says hey joe can't we just say yes
we can
and that's where the energy of the left
and the democrats is it has nothing to
do with the constitution
it has everything to do with just
exercising power whether it's opening up
a salon for yourself or taking
guns away if that's what you think is
right or letting people burn down cities
and the the idea that they're the
authentic duo
in this race uh yeah no it is it is not
the case
all right uh dave rubin who as we just
heard gets his haircut
in somebody's garage dave thank you very
much for joining us today from kind of a
noisy la thank you sir
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell